macomb county in michigan can make or
break
political dreams an enigma with serious
way
it is mostly white and working class and
in 2016
it swung to donald trump but the ground
below might
be slightly shifting you've changed your
mind about donald trump you voted for
him
in 2016. why well
i don't know at this point i don't even
know why i was ever with him to begin
with
he's not a good person he's unfit for
office
his character is is very bad
he's not getting results either how many
other people do you think
share your view though i think that
there's going to be enough
in macomb county that have observed him
over the last four years
who voted for him in 2016 that aren't
going to be able to do it again
and i think that you know people that
are working hard
that are honest decent people look at
him
and they they they've reached their
tipping point
democrats are pitching themselves as the
saviors of civility
but the gloves are well and truly off
for close to four years now he has shown
no interest in putting in the work
no interest in finding common ground no
interest
in using the awesome power of his office
to help
anyone but himself and his friends
that message though needs to resonate
with suburban women
and there's an almighty fight the silent
majority is a
seething lion yes ready to pounce
[Applause]
when i talk to women women women want
law and order
in their homes in their children in
their marriages
in their businesses women want law and
order
are you concerned at all about the way
that he speaks
about women no i really don't even the
access hollywood tapes
not at all you know what i did not vote
for him to be my
pastor i did not vote for him to date my
daughter
i voted for him to write this sinking
ship which is exactly what he's done
what are the challenges for donald trump
i think that i wish he was less
reactionary
but boy is it in him to fight he is a
fighter through and through
that felt like a mini maga rally with
cheese and wine
and there are loads of these events
happening across michigan what struck me
about it is just
how much they've adopted donald trump's
messaging
and phrasing and just how organized they
are
but oakland county is still democrat
whatever happens with women voters in
places like this
will define america's future